i'd love to ask you all what you're
thankful for because it's one of my
favorite traditions about thanksgiving
is that moment
where we get to say what we're thankful
for whether it's silly or meaningful and
everything in between
malin what are you thankful for in this
unprecedented year
oh in this unprecedented year i am
thankful for my wine subscription that
arrives at my doorstep once a month
yes it's getting me through
but i i obviously on a serious note
i'm so thankful that the silver lining
of all this is that i've gotten to spend
time with my son
and husband in a real way that i haven't
before
um and it has its pros and cons but wow
has it ever been amazing
and cat beautiful beautiful cat what are
you
thankful for um well
i was gonna say spending time with my
baby niece who
but now it's that you think i'm pretty
yeah
i i really do honestly that eclipses
anything else in my life that i'm never
going to be the same
um but my little niece was born
last september and being able to spend
all my free time with this baby and
watching her grow up and you know being
able to be there
with her i mean it's just i don't know
i'm really cherishing this time with
this
little noodle oh my gosh
um aisha what are you thankful for
in this wild year you know we're always
praying for a break i think in our own
lives you know like just
if we could slow time down and i think
you know
um we we wouldn't have preferred that it
happened this way
um this has been you know a real
hellscape of a year
and so it's made at least me hopefully
very present
with my family and my friends and i'm
lucky that my mom who's you know older
and really had to shelter in place
that we were able to get her close to us
and um
kind of come up with new ways to
interact with family you know in some
ways time has slowed down
and chelsea what are you thankful for
um i
forget i forget but
oh i know i'm always i'm really thankful
always for makeup um
i i've got these new pencils that i like
as like
if i'm feeling low i can just go like
that and then it's like
you know kind of a way of signaling that
i'm happy to people
also you can make like you know how
everyone acts surprised by the news all
the time even though it's the same kind
of stuff all the time
so you can make your eyes like whoa this
is shocking what's going on
and you know there's a lot of lips you
can do so this is
getting me through do you have a look
for
anger um sure why not i can what about
it makes me think like a furrowed brow
kind of like
this give that and then maybe um
hmm what would make you oh like what
about like angry teeth
yeah and then it's like and then go
ahead oh yeah
yes that works that works okay
now what if that same person wanted to
flirt
oh now see when you flirt what do you do
ladies what do you do you know you do a
red lip
so yeah and see aisha has the perfect
lip and i can only
pretend to compare but here you have a
bit of angry a bit of flirty a shocked
that is my normal look yeah that is
always
yeah and you're known for that look
you've been reading my diary
yeah oh my god that crying tape
elsie paint some tears on real quick
yeah we need a few tears
oh hold on i can do that
beautiful
i mean
now drooling
i i mean i just
you know i didn't have like family
growing up and that's not a boohoo
it's like my friends became my family i
got to find a family a chosen family
and it's my loyalty and love for them is
as thick as any
blood i've ever come across or known
because i'm always in bloody situations
and i do judge the blood and i think
hey my friends are thicker than you
anyway
the point is i love um
the life i've gotten to live with my
friends and so to put out a movie
that's holiday-oriented comedic and
friendship-based
you have my heart this is a great thing
to put out into the world thank you for
doing so
thanks thank you thank you so much
friendsgiving is now available in
theaters and
on demand it is the holiday medicine
that we all got prescribed and
desperately need
thank you so much i am so excited to be
hanging out with you i don't want to
leave i don't want this to end luckily i
have the film
to plug into anytime i need thank you
[Music]
guys
you